everybody loves you guys on the show we
love the show but I also hear that
you're a musical which I did not know
did you just like DJ like EDM is that
what is that real I like that you came
to me first instead of the real musician
no because I just I just love like how
random I didn't know that yeah well I
wanted to I was really into it I was
pretty good at it beat matching like
records and stuff and I love that music
um good house music from the late 2000s
yeah and I love the club scene but I
never quite made it to where I was
really doing it as a real thing but you
love it it's not compassion and I'm a
moment
um no I love it though you've been in
several bands right yeah I've been
playing music since I was little grew up
in church started playing drums in
church when I was like nine ten years
old something like that and
um yeah I've been in bands since I can
remember do you still play like all the
time uh yeah I do I I'm gonna be putting
some music out here pretty soon look I
don't I hear it your voice I'm not as
good as you in the country I'm going
country I'm very great
that's right because I love country
music I've always wanted to make a
country record so I heard that that's
what you're doing so I was very excited
thank you yeah that's so cool do you
hang out in Nashville ever are you ever
in that scene or anything yeah I was
just there for like a couple months this
year actually doing some riding and kind
of just meet in the town and getting to
know everybody and it's such a cool
community so cool yeah yeah
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
I'm going
home
[Music]